hi I'm Erik Bosse and everything we know
about the Avengers confrontation with
Thanos could have changed with the new
release of never-before-seen concept art
depicting alternate versions of infinity
war and perhaps some imagery that could
inspire Avengers for all the art came in
this book and it's big actually to find
someone over the age of 40 to explain
what a book even is but I'm gonna sing a
lot of few key images that show totally
alternate versions of the final battle
against Thanos and explain what these
could mean spoiler warning in case I get
anything right and it ruins your life
somehow now the first thing I find
interesting is a design of Thanos his
fight with Iron Man Doctor Strange
spider-man the guardians on Titan for me
this was the most well designed sequence
of the film because we got to see Thanos
use the Infinity stones in a variety of
interesting ways sometimes in
combination and all the heroes
complement these attacks with unique
powers of their own I never felt like
anyone was less useful than the others
or sidelined everyone ended up landing
key blows at different times and
everyone was overpowered at other times
and everything had weight looking at the
art that went into designing the
sequence you can see how much creativity
was needed to pull this off and the art
that got left on the cutting room floor
is even more interesting notice dr.
strange in these images in an interview
for this book one of the artists singled
out strange as the most pivotal
character in the sequence and they
called his fight with Thanos Nev Weiser
dude at one point this duel was going to
feature dr. strange touching thanasis
forehead to put him in a trance and the
movie looks a lot like the one that the
ancient one used on strange in dr.
strange when she spun them off their
various realities and some of the other
photos confirm that some version of that
Doctor Strange imagery was intended to
be part of this duel you can see strange
and Thanos fighting in some
interdimensional tunnel with the shards
of the mirror dimensions surrounding
them Thanos appears to be in between
this space in another surface on the far
right a flat plane that looks a lot like
that eyeball portal that strains it
through on his magical mystery tour
essentially it sounds like Doctor
Strange was gonna try to disorient
Thanos the same way that the ancient one
disoriented him which would be a very
smart tactic because magic and the
mystic arts is one form of power that
Thanos even with four Infinity stones
might not fully comprehend now there's
another concept art image showing Thanos
fighting the full group with him using
one of his Infinity stones the placement
suggests the mine stone to blast these
astral projection
formed out of their physical bodies you
look closely each of these forms show
the heroes out of armor like Peter quill
has his mask removed and Tony Stark is
wearing normal clothes and he could see
Peter Parker's face now I know it
wouldn't make sense for thinness to have
the mine stone yet unless there was an
old version of the story where he got it
from vision before fighting the others
untighten also this stone looks a little
blue to me suggesting that it could be
the space stone either way one of the
nurses moves at one point during the
development process was going to be
using a stone to deep power each of the
Avengers or maybe extracting their minds
or their souls from their bodies but
let's move on to the final showdown in
Wakanda which to me has the most
interesting alternate ending according
to this art originally thanasis was
going to face all of the Wakanda
Avengers at once with them dogpiling on
him and trying to hold him down
similarly the way that the Titan
Avengers did this case cap Black Panther
Groot Black Widow and the Hulk not
suffering from performance anxiety in
this version but in his full green form
instead of banner in the Hulkbuster
armor all restraining Thanos while Thor
comes in with Stormbreaker apparently it
would have played out the same Thor
hitting Venice in the chest
Thanos saying you should have gone for
the head and snapping but in this case
the snap would have happened perfectly
in frame width or as well as cap net and
the Hulk
several Avengers at once would react
with shock to that moment it seems like
the filmmakers reassigned this cool
team-up restrained image to the battle
on Titan and instead Thanos discharged
on Wakanda was more of a direct Death
March with Thanos swatting down each
Avenger one by one and that makes his
final moment with Thor smaller and more
intimate the way we see it in the final
cut of the film it feels like these two
are the last two beings on earth and it
briefly frames the entire infinity war
story as a tale of two heroes Thor and
Thanos zeroes each on a journey to
complete a new Valyrian weapon - in
their eyes save the universe the fact
that Thanos is victorious in this moment
makes the entire movie his story Thanos
does have more screen time than any
other character in this movie then again
he's not totally the hero because his
shirtless shots were left out of the
movie damn that's it I think that these
visuals suggest that Thor's Redemption
from this defeat would play a bigger
role in the next Avengers movie you
gotta get this book because so much of
the concept art here centers around Thor
like his alternate
storyboards of his opening fight with
Thanos and the forging of Stormbreaker
now there's a lot more I could say about
this but I actually want to dig deep
into this in another video how my
question for you here is would you
prefer the Wakanda battle to be more
exciting as it is in this concept art or
do you prefer the more intense Thanos
fight being untighten as it was in the
movie comment down below with your
thoughts and follow new rockstars on
twitter instagram at new rockstars and
for my personal weird ramblings follow
me on twitter and instant a live in the
LA area guys you've got to come see my
Marvel parodies show infinity fan before
Marvel finds out about it and sues me
it's got everything it's got Infinity
Gauntlet it's got the iron spider armor
it's got a Stan Lee cameo actually the
whole thing is kind of a Stan Lee cameo
look you just got to come and see it to
understand it it's on Friday November
16th 8 p.m. Acme theatre North Hollywood
ticket info in the description below and
subscribe to this channel for more
breakdowns of everything Marvel and
Avengers related and sooner or later
we're gonna do an explanation of what
exactly a book is apparently you just
open it and you turn the pages like
[Music]